لقاء خاصه الان ضمن جوله المنتصف نستضيف
في هنا في الاستوديو السيد لويجي دي مايو
وزير الخارجيه الايطالي السابق والممثل
الخاص للاتحاد الاوروبي لمنطقه الخليج
اهلا بك سيد دروجيدي مايو مرحبا بك اذا ما
انطلقنا بتصريحات اسلامي الخاصه للجزيره
والذي ربط فيها موضوع خفض الالتزام
بالاتفاق النووي برفع كامل للعقوبات على
ايران كيف ترون هذا الشرط
النقطه الاولى بالنسبه الينا والتي هي في
غايه الاهميه هي ما يتعلق بمنع الانتشار
النووي وكاتحاد اوروبي نحن
المسهلون
لمائده التفاوض لاعاده
ايران الى الاتفاق النووي السابق او خطه
عمل المشتركه
الشامله للحد من الانتشار لكن نحن كاتحاد
اوروبي علينا ان نكون جاهزين للعمل مع كل
بلدان المنطقه التي تعمل على التخفيف في
حده التصعيد في المنطقه وفي رايي الحوار
بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه والطيران هو
امر مرحب به للغايه ونحن ندعم كل الحوارات
وكل عمليات بهذا الاتجاه اتجاه تخفيف
التصعيد في المنطقه
فرضت عقوبات على ايران ماذا عن العقوبات
المتعلقه
بالصواريخ الباليستيه المقرر ان تنتهي
وينتهي اجلها في اكتوبر
اعتقد انه فيما يتعلق
بالتخفيف من التصعيد والعمل الذي نقوم به
من اجل الحث على الحوار الاتحاد الاوروبي
كان في الصداره لاننا كنا في موقع الصداره
فيما يتعلق بالعمل الدبلوماسي ولاننا نؤمن
ايمانا راسخا بان الدبلوماسيه هي الحل
الحقيقي
لبسط الاستقرار في المنطقه ومن دون
استقرار بالطبع لن يكون هناك تنميه
اقتصاديه وبالحديث عن المنطقه تم تعيينكم
مؤخرا كسفير الاتحاد الاوروبي في منطقه
الخليج هذا لاول مره ما دلاله هذا التعيين
نعم هذا هو التعيين الاول لممثل الخاص
لمنطقه الخليج للاتحاد الاوروبي وانا تم
تعييني من قبل الاعضاء السبعه والعشرين
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا يعكس مستوى الطموح
الجديد حول شراكات الاتحاد مع بلدان
المنطقه واضح ان عندما نتحدث عن شراكه
ودول المجلس التعاون فهذا اكثر تطورا لكن
الاتحاد الاوروبي يريد التواصل والعمل مع
كل البلدان التي تريد العمل لتعزيزي الامن
والاستقرار والحوار في المنطقه وعند
تعيينك قال المجلس الاوروبي ان هذا
التعيين ومهامك ستتمثل في تطوير شراكه
استراتيجيه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول
الخليج على ماذا
تتركز هذه الشراكه
التفويض الذي
مرتكز الى خمس ركائز اولها الاستثمار حيث
هناك الكثير من عمليات الانتقال في
اقتصاداتنا والكل يحاول تنويع مصادر دخله
واقتصاده ونحن سويه يمكن ان نغتنم بعض
الفرص هناك ايضا امن الطاقه والتغيرات
المناخير وكيف يمكن العمل سويه في ضوء
مؤتمر 28 في دوله المعروفه العربيه
المتحده في السابعه المقبله وقبل نهايه
العامه لانها نعمل سويت لتحقيق اهدافنا
المشتركه وامننا ايضا الركيزه الثالثه كما
قلنا كل عمليات الحوار والتواصل حول تعزيز
الاستقرار مرحب بها الركيزه الرابعه تتعلق
بالناس بالشعوب حيث نحاول الترويج
لمشروعات من شانها التقريب بين مجتمعات
وصعوبنا ونعمل سويه لتعزيز التفاهم
المشترك والاحترام المشترك وكيف يمكن ان
ندافع عن حقوق مواطنينا وهذا مهم ما حدث
حول حرقه نسخه المصحف هذا لم يكن انتهاكا
لقواعد الاتحاد الاوروبي وقيمه مبادئ
الاحترام لكن كان مهما ايضا لتعزيز
الاحترام المتبادل اخيرا فيما يتعلق
بالجيل الجديد من العلاقات بين مؤسساتنا
في العاشر من اكتوبر في مسقط ستتاح لنا
الفرصه لننظم لقاء بين وزراء خارجيه دول
نفس التعاون ووزراء خارجيه الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي ليكون علامه فارقه جديده في
علاقاتنا لنمضي قدما في خطوات جديده الى
الامام وبما انك ذكرت موضوع حرق المصحف ما
الدور الملقى على الاتحاد الاوروبي كتله
واحده لمنع تكرار تصرفاتك هذه هو انت ترى
جيدا تداعياتها في المنطقه ككل وفي العالم
تكون
اعتقد ان حرق اي كتاب مقدس
المهين ولا ينم عن الاحترام وامر مشين ليس
فقط لا يلم عن احترام لكن قيمنا نحن
كاوروبيين يمسها مثل هذا العمل لهذا السبب
في هذه المنطقه لكنه نقرب بين مجتمعاتنا
ونمهد لمشروعات جديده ونروج للتبادل
الاحترام المتبادل يجب ان ندين هذه
الاعمال لانها مرفوضه وليست مقبوله اشكرك
جزيل الشكر سيد الوجي دماغي الوزير
الخارجيه الايطالي السابق والممثل الخاص
للاتحاد الاوروبي لمنطقه الخليج ضيفنا هنا
في الاستوديو شكرا جزيلا لك